[Musik]
dann bleibt noch daran dafür heute auf
ein paar video reagieren werden
ihr seht wahrscheinlich gerade nur
schwarz eingeblendet falls ihr euch
fragen sollte haye luca was sma keine
ahnung
ich habe keine ahnung und was macht man
keine ahnung hat dann spricht später
keinen job smrz century meridian red
jetzt weiß ich immer noch nicht was
vorfällt die sma bezeichnet ein
emotionales kopf kribbeln das als
angenehm und beruhigend empfunden wir
dieses kribbeln wird durch ville bereits
auf verschiedenen villen oder legten
ausgelöst beispielsweise durch
berührungen am kopf beim friseurbesuch
bestimmte geräusche ruhige stimme oder
eine persönliche aufmerksamkeit durch
eine andere version wow
ok
ich weiß noch nicht genau was gesetzt um
jetzt mal zu diesem schwarzen screen
hier zu kommen warum medien dort
eingeblendet
ganz einfache grund dahinter ist dass
dieses video ema entspanntes unboxing
fine food box everything tapping
stretching in german deutsch wurde mir
bei empfohlen angezeigt also youtube
denkt ich sollte mir mal elf im augen-
oder ich weiß noch wie ich kein normaler
user bin habe ich gedacht ich klicke
einfach mal auf play und wir statt
was macht mit ihren fingern
es ist sehr kritisch ganz kurze sache am
rande soll nicht beleidigend oder böse
gegenüber der youtuber in sein die
hochgeladen hat oder dieser elberding
also wenn sich das leute geben wollen
und die darin in tieferen sinn wenn dann
bin ich voll auf eurer seite m ich finde
das ganze allerdings so ein bisschen
suspekt aber bitte versteht dass ich
mich überhaupt nicht aber irgendwie
nützlich machen bild wollte nur mal mit
euch live auf bananen krumm
[Musik]
was
das sei irgendwie so herzlich willkommen
heute hier zu diesen mut unboxing was
ist ein 18 food wahrscheinlich weil ich
bin bei der lautstärke hier aufwächst
ich hab noch nie so laut dem was auf
meinen kopf ich weiß was passiert denn
jetzt mittel liegt anmache
also ich bin jetzt hier bei einem
metal-fan angekommen wir drücken jetzt
einfach mal auf sogar noch durch diese
verdammten kopfhörer hier
[Musik]
alter schwede was ist dass man nie weiß
nicht ob sie weinen oder lachen soll
du machst das unboxing du sollst essen
[Musik]
warten wir lassen noch mal ganz kurz
weiter reden was ist der genaue grund
ist okay also wir können auf jeden was
macht ihr eigentlich die hat wirklich
wieso hat mich die ganze zeit auf also
beim herzblatt ihre kamera um gespann
beim zweiten mal war der fernseher an
das nicht beim ersten mal aufgefallen
beim dritten mal ist dann der akku leer
gegangen und jetzt ist sie beim vierten
mal also mal schauen ob sie das schafft
was ist das
ich sagte petzel aus sollte ein buch
über essen das wäre genauso wie wenn ich
sagen würde haye ich zeig euch heute die
cristiano ronaldo kind beispiel dann
habe ich auch nur im fußball
nein es ist nicht so locker als auch
scheißegal was war das warum die typen
die das misstrauen ist jetzt keine box
ist es im buch
und was bedeutet dieses drauf und in
bern ist auch ein teil von el pais
bereits zu beginn gesagt die wirklich
böse sein ich bin einfach nur ein
bisschen was passiert wenn er in die
schweiz verhalten nichts drüber
also ich höre noch nicht in meinem kopf
was in wikipedia stand dass man ihnen
ich weiß nicht was mit einem passiert
vielleicht ich weiß nicht vielleicht
entspannt man also oder wird in alien
mein magen knurrt
[Musik]
das ist das projekt was sie hat
prospekte über eine box zu gesicht
bekommen hat und diese box ist essen
drin und das stellt uns vor ist es nicht
eigentlich sogar eine falsche
kennzeichnung von werbung aber freue
mich wenn ich die landesmedienanstalt
nrw und muss das ganze aufwecken nein
ich bin crafter ich muss
nur
das muss ich eigentlich warum
warum
[Musik]
da
also ich weiß nicht wie dieses video
weitergeht aber irgendwie glaube ich ist
er hoffe ich zumindest nicht dass die un
wollen forscher das bild also ich dachte
die werden
die produkte
[Musik]
wenn es bequem mit pin haltet auch müsse
ziemlich komisch
[Musik]
hast du dich überhaupt opfer waren 2000
jahre später endlich wieder flüssig
mensch die fifa ja fast schon raus etwas
us-dollars genau zeitungsabonnenten aber
sagt wir gerade so weit mich ob es
erkenntnisse angetrieben aber die sich
so süß
wie sollen wir das denn erkennen das ist
wie die leute wie zu beginn schon gewagt
ist nicht bereit gefühlt somit jedes mal
aber ich weiß dass viele leute ihren
kommentaren wahrscheinlich das verstehen
werden habe ich habe keinen bock dass
die hate abbekommen weil es im blog
haben viele leute und die hat er 10.000
abonnenten locker viele leute dort
feiern und für die das irgendwie
beruhigend ist oder so weiß man welche
krankheiten keine ahnung was ich bin
teil der amüsante das anzugucken
ich mach das schiere distanz drüber
streicheln und fertig ich könnte mich
nicht so lang vor die kamera stellen und
müsste nicht wird dann also hüttenberg
da komm ich muss irgendwie scheint klar
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen dass das für
mich nichts ist also wenn ich mir das
jetzt noch länger anschauen würde dann
würde ich glaube ich er irgendwie gar
nicht mehr klar kommt in meinem leben
tue ich ja auch schon nicht will ich
wirklich er gar nicht mehr klarkommen
als das nicht irgendwie entspannter
angehen könnte aber das ist ja irgendwie
drin und ich würde sagen wir schauen wir
noch ein paar anderen helfer immer
videos
die leute die das machen können sich
also masseurin einen kay sind sogar ein
paar hübschen meinen augen dabei also
ich möchte auch video drauf und wir
sehen schon auch holt eine schere und
wasserspritzer ja gut fangen wir mit dem
video
also jetzt ganz im ernst wie etwa in
mega hübsches mädchen wie ein hammer
augen kleiner körper keine ahnung ist
die deutschen nicht oder eine deutsche
bundeswehr kann es ist dass vor ort js
ich habe heute abend eigentlich kein
mehr erwartet aber wir schauen uns das
video von hier mal weiter an
[Musik]
glaubt wirklich dass sie eine deutsche
also ich hab das wird gerade mal 20
sekunden geschaut aber
[Musik]
nochmal warte ich mach das mal ganz kurz
ein halber geschwindigkeit hier
[Musik]
sagt hat
logisch meinte
[Musik]
flug am 1
ok ok 15 kräften film ok ok ich rede mit
einem youtube-video hey leute spaß also
ich hatte ja lustig das video geht noch
wurde es geht doch 18 minuten leute an
dieser stelle will ich das video aber
auch beendet wird das mittlerweile was
ich mich eingelassen habe wenn euch das
video hier gefallen hat dass die fetten
like dauern schreibt in die kommentare
wenn ich nochmal die du machen soll oder
darauf weiter reagieren sondern bisschen
mit ihr sprechen soll
aber er findet jetzt auf jeden fall hier
oben ein smiley eingeblendet werden
darauf könnte man kann kostenlos
abonnieren verpasst dadurch keine videos
mehr
und darum bin ich auch meinen job
eingeblendet in dem gibt es neue
sommersachen und t shirt und so und hier
unten ist ein weiteres video hey wer
jetzt gedacht
ja jeder